en este primer problema se nos pide
encontrar la longitud del segmento c
aquí podemos ver que tenemos líneas
paralelas a b y d y tenemos estas dos
líneas que son transversales y que
forman estos dos triángulos vamos a ver
qué podemos hacer
lo primero que observamos es que estos
dos ángulos son ángulos verticales y por
lo tanto son congruentes y otra cosa que
puede notar es que este otro ángulo
cdeee es un ángulo interior alterno con
el que es formado por los segmentos c b
y por lo tanto van a ser congruentes
otra forma de verlo es que si yo
extiendo esta línea un poco más veremos
que aquí tenemos un ángulo
correspondiente a este otro de cualquier
manera este ángulo y este otro ángulo
van a ser congruentes aquí hemos
establecido entonces que tenemos dos
triángulos y dos de sus ángulos son
iguales y esto por sí solo es suficiente
para establecer una similitud incluso
podríamos demostrar que estos dos
ángulos son congruentes pero realmente
no es necesario
de todas formas ya sabemos que estos dos
triángulos son similares así que vamos a
dibujar aquí los ángulos que son
congruentes aunque ya sabíamos que son
similares aún antes de hacer esto vamos
ahora a dibujar aquí y voy a usar un
código de colores para no confundir
nuestros ángulos ya que es importante no
confundir que ángulos y qué lados
corresponden con cuáles otros para no
echar a perder nuestras proporciones así
que el triángulo a ver a ver
triángulo a b c triángulo abc es similar
similar al triángulo formado por el
vértice de aquí corresponde al vértice
de aquí así que similar a él y el
vértice b de acá es correspondiente al
vértice de de este lado así que similar
a d y nos queda el de c y esto que nos
indica bueno nos dice que la proporción
de los lados va a ser la misma tendremos
algún valor constante entonces la
proporción correspondiente al segmento b
c b se va a ser la misma que la del
segmento de c así que aquí lo indicamos
veces es proporcional al segmento de s
lo que nos parece aquí bastante obvio
veces es proporcional a de s
así que aquí abajo lo escribimos veces
entre la longitud del segmento c de udc
aquí lo escribimos va a ser igual a
nuestra interrogante el segmento c y
aquí estamos usando los segmentos b c y
c d porque conocemos ya estos valores b
c entre de se va a ser igual a nuestro
segmento c entre su segmento
correspondiente que va a ser el segmento
a c o sea así que nos queda sea entre sí
así pues nuestra expresión queda bc en
trece de iguala c
entre s
aquí conocemos algunos valores el valor
debe ser
5 el valor de dc es 3
el valor de c
es 4 y nuestra incógnita el valor de c
es lo que tenemos que calcular pensemos
cómo podemos resolver esto una cosa que
podemos hacer es multiplicar ambos lados
de esta igualdad por ambos denominadores
entonces nos quedaría 5 x c e igual a 3
x 4 12 aquí escribimos 12 ahora si
divido ambos lados
entre 5 me va a quedar sea igual a 12
quintos 12 quintos que esto es lo mismo
que dos enteros y dos quintos así que el
valor de nuestro segmento c es 2 enteros
y dos quintos y como ven pudimos
encontrar este valor simplemente
conociendo la proporción de este otro
triángulo que es similar a éste que
estamos analizando ahora vamos a dibujar
una línea aquí para separar lo que va a
ser un nuevo problema en este otro
problema lo que tenemos que encontrar es
el valor del segmento de nuevamente
vemos que aquí tenemos dos líneas
paralelas así
sabemos que los ángulos correspondientes
van a ser congruentes el ángulo en el
vértice a es igual que el que está en el
vértice b ya que esta es una transversal
y nuevamente vemos que de este lado este
ángulo va a ser congruente con el ángulo
que se encuentra aquí arriba por lo
mismo hay una transversal y no sólo eso
estos dos triángulos de aquí el que
formado por c b y d y el formado por c
pues comparten el mismo vértice llamado
c por lo tanto también tienen el mismo
ángulo ahora resulta evidente que estos
dos triángulos comparten los mismos
ángulos y por lo tanto son congruentes
entre sí es importante recordar que
tenemos que escribir las cosas en el
orden correcto cuando estamos
describiendo triángulos similares así
que tenemos que el triángulo
ven
es similar
no congruente similar al triángulo
formado por c
ah
cada vértice en ambos triángulos está en
el orden correspondiente y ahora podemos
decir que la proporción correspondiente
entre el segmento se ve de hecho vamos a
escribirlo aquí se ve entre sí
va a ser igual al segmento c de entre c
y ahora podemos sustituir los valores
conocemos el valor del segmento se ve
que es 5 el segmento se ha c
va a ser 5 + 3 o sea va a ser 8 por aquí
escribimos 8 sabemos cuánto vale cdc de
vale 4 haber aquí hacemos un poquito de
espacio y vamos a despejar un poco vamos
a multiplicar ambos lados de la igualdad
por los denominadores así que nos queda
5% de este otro lado es 8 por 4 32
y ahora se va a ser igual a 32
entre 5 y esto es igual a 6 enteros 2
quintos pero esperen aún no terminamos
pues lo que nos piden es el segmento de
y hemos encontrado el segmento c pero
esto ya no es muy difícil porque lo que
vamos a hacer es restar lo que es el
segmento cd4 a este valor que calculamos
así que nuestro segmento d
va a ser igual a 6 enteros dos quintos
menos 4 o sea 2 enteros 2 quintos y
ahora si ya hemos terminado la respuesta
es 2 enteros 2 quintos